what if you lose I mean Tyson's already
made it clear what his reaction will be
which is basically disowning you by the
sound of it but for you to to lose to
someone who's not even a real boxer that
would be Unthinkable right
of course and that's why that's not an
option there is no way that this man
could beat me even if he had a hammer in
both hands and I'm going to exhibit that
yeah I've made it two rules in life
never fight anyone called Tyson or Fury
just seems to me to be an active
self-arm that
well soon it's going to be never fight
anyone called Tyson and never fight
anyone called Tommy because I'm going to
prove that under four weeks